はい皆さんこんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
何が好きかご存知でしょうか？
〇っぱいです。
まあ男子高校生になればこう少なからずこうやっぱ
女の子に興味を抱いてます、普通はね×２
普通は抱いてますよ(言えてない)(興奮気味)
もうそれはもう僕も例外ではなく
もう男子高校生にもなると女性の体がすごいガッ気になりすぎてて(興奮気味)
もうたぶん
要するに。
女性の胸の膨らみなどにとても敏感になる時期でありまして、
今家にですね
高校生のYouTuberのつる兄ってやつが遊びに来ております。
今ちょっとパシリで買い物に行かせているんですけど
やっぱ彼もなんやかんや、一匹の男。
そして、男子高校生であるので、
まあ正常な男子高校生ならば、
胸が大好きなはず。
すなわち、胸の膨らみには過剰な反応を示すはずでございます。
てことは、仮に僕が女性じゃなくても、
僕の胸が少しでもこう膨らんでいる、少しでもこうちょっと…
ruru…
露(ろ)に
露(あらわ)になってる感じであれば
男性であっても胸の膨らみに興味を示すのではないか
すぐ見破られるのではないか、ということで
男子高校生は本当に胸が好きなのか、過剰に反応するのかということを検証していきたいと思います。
(真面目に冷静に説明してるけどめっちゃ可笑しいｗｗ)
僕は純粋にですよ！？僕は純粋に男子高校生である彼の、
一人の男としての胸に対する熱い思い、熱意、興味というものを
どれだけのものなのか、っていうことをちょっと実験で確かめてみたいと思っております。
というわけで、
これすごいんですよ、
つけると5倍盛りに胸が、盛れるというやつです。(つけてみたい)
そもそも胸がないから～…
がさがさ
パカッ
うわあ
あれこれでもさ…えっ？
これ待ってでもさ、これ…えっ？
なんかあれが無いとダメじゃん　(ブラ…？)
これだけだとたぶん…ダメだよ。
うわっでもなんか…エッ、でもなんか(2回目)
あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”
あ～そういうね。
初めて知ったわ(笑)
ヌーブラ、これを、これヌーブラっていうんですけど、この胸につけると、
胸が盛れるっていうやつなんですよ。
そう、だからこの方もきっとすごいこうやって盛ってるんですよ。(女性必見ですね)
えっヌーブラって書いてあったから普通にブラかと思ったら…
笑
俺なnあ”あ”あ”あ”あ”
つー乳首が吸い取られるぞ
えっこれすごいっすよなんか。
ヌーブラの中ってスッ、これなんかこうやって…くっつくんですよ。(私も知らなかった)
だから直接胸につけると乳首が…
あ”あ”やばいちょっと待って乳首とれるんじゃねこれ
あぁ…
デーーーーン！
おおお！
おお！あっ きたわ、きたきたきた
はい、はい、tｗｗｗ
うわあ～
あ やっぱマジか普通にやっぱ胸にダイレクトにつけるものなのか
分かりやすければいいんｄああ～はは(笑)
アッアッアッ
アッアッォアッう～わ
うわああぁあぁあぁ
わあああああああ！！(大興奮)
うわああ！あっいるいるいるいる、いるいる
うわｈっおっおっ(興奮気味)俺だ俺は。これ俺か。
おっほぉｗｗｗ
あぁ、良い～サイズ感ですねぇ
というわけで、もう帰ってきてるんですけども、(小声)
どれくらいの時間でつる兄が僕の胸に気付くかを検証していきたいと思います。
ではっ！
(実況風)さあいよいよ始まりました！
胸を確認しつつ、ターゲットが来るのを待つ！
さあパシリから帰ってきますターゲット！
やっと来ましたエロガッパつる兄です！
おっCCレモンを忘れたようですねぇ。(はじめんとつる兄何か話してるけど字幕不可能なのでカットします)
さあどう出る。
胸にはまだ気づいていないか。
おーっといきなり大胆なアプローチ！！
胸の存在に気付いているかすでに…！
だがこれは無意識のようだ！
さあ何気ない会話をしている中でターゲットは胸に気付くことができるのか
目線はかなり向いているがまだ胸には気づいていないようです。
さあここでどう仕掛けるかっ！
効果音(アーン//)　おっと！胸をあげる！
う”あ～これは分かりやすい！目線も行っているが、わずかに逸れる！
外れた、まだ気づいていない！
そして固まる空気！謎の沈黙。
何気ないときは二人は普段、動画のネタの話をしていますが。
さあここからどうアプローチをかけるか！
ここから見ても胸の膨らみは分かりやすいぞ！
さあどう仕掛ける！
効果音(アーン//)　おっと胸を上げた！
お互いにため息をつく。人生に疲れているのか！？
さあこの後どう仕掛けるか
胸の膨らみはここからでも確認できますので
あとはターゲットがどう反応できるかでございます。
おっ。あーーーー笑ってしまった！”なぜ気付かない”といった顔！
これは分かりやすいぞ！？
(笑)　分からないかまだ。
いやあ～これは分かるでしょさすがに！
俺だってわかるよ。
おーーっと！
これはセクシーポーズ！！つる兄の視線が向かった！
つ「ｗｗｗｗ」
バレたーーーーー！！
つる兄「ｗｗｗｗｗｗ」
つ「いや、その、おっぱい…ｗｗｗｗ」
つ「おっぱい。」
はじめしゃちょーの動画に字幕付けたのは初めてでしたが、動画の細部までじっくり楽しめていいですね！
不十分な点、ご不満に思う点もあるかと思いますが
字幕を付けて楽しんでくれた方、ありがとうございました！
では最後に、
おっぱい。